[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
lane kiffin set to join us the ole miss
head coach he'll be in tuscaloosa this
weekend against alabama
you know before i talk about that match
up coach
i i saw where michael wilbon said
something on pardon the interruption
where he uh was calling you out saying
you hadn't done anything called you a
clown
and you did respond to him a little bit
so
where did this come from what what
happened with you and michael wilbon
yeah it's interesting for a guy that
i've never met so
um
i
someone sent it to me um i thought it
was kind of like i was like wow that was
pretty aggressive i thought that was
kind of more like a chat room or a you
know a tennessee fan or something like
that you know would say not a national
media member so
and then people were like did you do
something wrong to this guy i was like i
never met him so whatever you know i'm
sure it increased his ratings or
something but but do you engage with
people who are critical of whatever
you've done i mean how often does this
happen i know michael was on pardon the
interruption but how often do you engage
back and forth
uh i usually don't i just said something
on twitter just because it was so
aggressive just to kind of
you know i've been in a
in a twitter mood here the last two
years and our people love it our
recruits love it so
i just sent something off off um dealing
with that uh why is game day not gonna
be at your game with alabama
i don't know i
i thought they would but
you know going to athens
well
but what do they expect is going to
happen in athens or what did they expect
was going to happen in tuscaloosa
i don't know um i don't know how that
works maybe they've been to tuscaloosa a
million times and
didn't want to go back or something i'm
not sure
i love the fact that you were telling
people stop upsetting nick saban like
don't say these things you know like you
know he's got issues with his team
how good is that team of the recent
teams that nick has had
it's great and like i said you know
cherry picking didn't mean a negative
thing it just meant okay hey go tech
take the best people you know that are
out there
and film like free agency in nfl and
you know it is a crazy setup because
they basically pick first with all the
five stars in the draft and now they got
free agency on top of it to go grab a
great receiver or a great middle
linebacker you know if you have a small
hole so now maybe we're at times over
the years or
was one or two holes there now there's
nothing
but do you think you played a role or
how much of a role that you
it felt like opened nick's eyes to a
whole different offense here now they're
getting that quarterback they're getting
those wide receivers whereas they used
to just get offensive linemen and
running backs
yeah i do think that it's not i've been
opening his eyes i just think our
success in going faster and having
bigger stats offensively
i mean i know what it was like
recruiting against him you know at
tennessee or usc you know you were going
to get a defensive player away from him
for the most part you weren't going to
get like you said a lineman running back
but you know quarterbacks and receivers
you know you could say okay you're going
to go there and be a game manager you
know you're not going to have many
catches julio jones one of the greatest
of all times had like 70 or something
you know and so um then when we go there
amari cooper has 128 you know that that
really changes
how you can not just recruit local but
nationally and then you see naji harris
come from california and and to uh you
know come from hawaii
and you know i think it just opened up a
pipeline that
now i got to deal with it here here at
ole miss and play them you're bryce
young from california
how much film do you watch of alabama
a lot
defensive side a little bit offensively
but you know you can't can't do all of
it but
we watch a lot of it we
know defensively what they usually do
they don't change a ton
so but yeah we watch a lot
but what do you tell your quarterback
what do you tell matt
um
you know nothing different than any
other
any other game that we play you know you
got reads you gotta
you know take care of the ball you know
this game different than most games you
just got elite players everywhere
um 31 the defensive end i bet when
elvary's eligible a year from now you
know be the first pick of the draft type
of guy
so you know you don't have very long
with the ball the windows are really
tight you know it's more like an nfl
game you know that's what it looks like
when you're watching like
obviously nfl players but
in the nfl there may be a hole and it
closes really quick you know you don't
have a lot of explosive plays
and that's what it's like
who does uh your quarterback remind you
of
i mean i'm going to say this and he's
not patrick mahomes but the release
points and the arm angles this ability
to throw
what
99 of the world can't
you know is really special
when did you know you had something
special
well we didn't have spring with him we
had like some workouts and just see him
throwing the deep ball right away i said
i didn't know how well he could think
how he could move at that time but i
knew the guy had an elite arm strength
and so to do what he did last fall and
you know most yards i think in in the
country without a spring in the new
system you know says a lot about him
talking to lane kiffin the ole miss head
coach he's got alabama coming up on
saturday then you host arkansas then
you're uh at auburn what was it like
when you couldn't coach your team
against louisville in atlanta what are
you allowed to contribute
on game day
yeah you can't once it starts you know i
was in every zoom every meeting
you know even the pregame meal you know
via zoom that stuff but once it started
uh you are not allowed which really
doesn't make a whole lot of sense why
can you be in a press box you know um
but you can't be on a headset you know
talking to them when you have coco but
it is what the rules are
how bad was it
uh it it was painful because you're
watching tv and it's
delayed a few seconds and
you know you're just not in control
which is very hard for head coaches you
had no control
no i meant the illness
oh i gotcha
i want to start with the surprise
thing had like two bad days but that was
about it um
you know i'd been vaccinated which i
think helped a lot and then whatever
that iv thing they put in you some some
long name that i can't remember that
helped a lot how much nfl do you watch
now
i don't
really any
uh you just i don't know how you can as
a coach you know you're just
every sunday you're in here getting
ready for the next opponent
yeah but i just wonder are you
and you've talked about this before
we've talked about this that the nfl is
taking from college not the other way
around but can you see
things so there was nothing you could
see on a on a sunday in the nfl that you
could say that's applicable to my team
or i could my quarterback or my coaching
staff
it's backwards now
you know like we've discussed we used to
do that we used to have our guys cut up
you know hey cut up these different
routes and these different things you
know from
the chiefs or whatever the hot team was
and you know we do it a little bit in
the off season but not like use at all
it's really backwards they're they're a
couple years behind us and you watch the
chiefs you actually they're they're now
running the plays we were three four
years ago do you have a scripted answer
so when you're asked about would you be
interested in usc like do you get
together with the sports information
director or pr people and say all right
let's let's just come up with a nice
paragraph here do you already have that
i do not um but i can think this is the
first time i'm asked so i can think of
one quick i've been doing this a lot of
years um okay let me let let me answer
the question there
uh yeah uh coach kiffin uh uh are you
interested in going back to usc
you know i'm fully committed to where
i'm at you know this is a wonderful
place i love the people here you know
and anytime that we get attention like
that it's just a credit to our players
and what they're doing uh coach is there
unfinished business at usc
no i i don't even think that way dan i'm
just totally focused on our program here
uh
how do you feel whenever you're on the
tarmac coach
interesting dan i was on the same tarmac
and walked through the same fbo this
weekend when i went recruiting in la and
it was very eerie
same exact one and there was a little
office there to the right and you walked
through the private airport which is
where
pat hayden walked me in at 3 17 a.m and
so that was a little bit strange
so you walk by the office where you got
fired
yes it was actually just a little coffee
room that was in the in the private
airport there
is there a chalk outline of you or
anything there
that's kind of funny no
nobody knows
football or coaches any of that stuff
i respect you can laugh about it
sure you know everything happens for a
reason
you know you never would have went and
worked for nick saban had that not
happened
that's true and you know i this has
become sort of that stopover place for
coaches who
um almost need to revitalize their
careers i mean is that is nick taking in
people and knowing that that's what he's
he's helping them with
yeah i think there's two sets i think
there's you know the ones he bring in
that help him
and
you know and he helps as well you know
that our
offensive coordinate you know that are
coordinators
and then there's some he brings in you
know off the field as analysts so like
that just to kind of restart them
because they're you know
down and out or they're still under
contract somewhere so i think there's
kind of two sets with that
it's great to talk to you have fun and
can you have fun in tuscaloosa
have fun if you win
have fun in tuscaloosa thanks for
joining us coach all right dan have a
good weekend that's lane kiffin
i didn't know where we were going with
the tarmac question